ever watched a horror movie and wondered
just how those actors managed to get
through planes such terrifying and
disturbing roles well the truth is some
of them barely do these actors have
experienced everything from abusive
directors to creepy onset experiences to
full-blown psychological breakdowns here
are a few of the brave souls who took on
roles that ended up messing with their
heads screaming in space the chests
bursting seen an alien ranks among the
most iconic moments in sci-fi history
part of what made that moment so
impactful might be that the cast
involved had no idea what was about to
happen to them
director Ridley Scott made sure that the
creatures reveal would happen in real
time during shooting hoping for more
authentic reactions from his actors it
worked
actress Veronica Cartwright later
remembered you see this thing start to
come out so we all get sucked in we lean
forward to check it out all of a sudden
it comes out I tell you none of us
expected it it was Cartwright herself
who suffered the most intense reaction
of all to the scene when the blood hit
her during the take she passed out Hotel
trauma Stanley Kubrick pretty much
obliterated the psyche of actress
Shelley Duvall during shooting on his
adaptation of Stephen King's The Shining
his mistreatment of Duvall included
ordering cast and crew not to help her
when upset and actively hindering her
efforts to deliver her performance and
because the whole film was shot
chronologically the viewer is treated to
an entirely realistic portrayal of the
unraveling of someone's mental
well-being
according to Duvall Stanley pushed me
and prodded me further than I've ever
been pushed before it's the most
difficult role I've ever had to play she
had to keep bottles of water nearby on
set to keep her hydrated after her bouts
of hysterics and even confronted Kubrick
with clumps of her own hair to
demonstrate just how unwell she was
during the shoot perhaps worst of all
Kubrick forced her to perform her iconic
traumatic baseball-bat scene over and
over again across a stunning 127 takes
and he had concerned about me
of course you are
the omens curse Richard Donner's 1976
creep fest the omen has a rich history
of freaky incidents that solidified the
Antichrist centric flakes reputation as
one of the most cursed sets of all time
and it was Gregory Peck who bore the
brunt of the tragedy his son Jonathan
shot himself just two months prior to
production on the movie and then his
plane was struck by lightning
something that would also go on to
happen to the omens executive producer
mace Neufeld elsewhere during production
an animal handler would be mauled by a
tiger a special effects assistant would
be beheaded in a car crash near a car
sign which read omens 66.6 kilometers
and a plane originally chartered for use
on aerial shots during shooting would go
down in Israel killing everyone on board
these eerie happenings had everyone so
spooked that producer Harvey Bernhard
actually carried a cross with him on set
it was Bernhard who said of the omen the
devil was at work and he didn't want
that film a man in the mask during
shooting on the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
tobe Hooper withheld the appearance of
Leatherface from his actors until the
cameras actually started rolling Gunnar
Hansen who played Leatherface has spoken
of the difficulties endured by his
fellow cast members during filming on
the movies iconic dinner table scene he
said the whole dinner scene is burned in
my memory I think just because of the
misery of it at that point we were
really just on the verge of mental
collapse Marilyn burns who played Sally
experienced the worst of it burns
herself later told Hanson that I thought
you were really going to hurt me you
couldn't see through your stupid mask
[Music]
lost in the woods the Blair Witch
Project was filmed over the course of an
eight day camping trip if you can call
it that there was practically no
interaction between the cast and crew
safer a daily meeting meant to provide
the actors with supplies and
instructions on where to go next the
crew would then go on to stalk the
actors during the daytime rattle their
tents at night when they were sleeping
and as the shoot progressed give them
less and less food so they become
steadily more frustrated and exhausted
by each other no Mike it's not the same
lock it's not the same log Mike look
it's not the devil's work as a child
star of one of the most iconic horror
movies of all time Linda Blair
experienced no small number of side
effects from shooting The Exorcist
despite not really understanding much
about the depravity of the movie during
filming to her it was simply acting she
was faced with a litany of questions
after its release about possession
Catholicism in the nature of faith to
say she was unprepared for this as
something of an understatement she later
said to me The Exorcist was a work of
fiction
I didn't realize then that it dealt with
anything in reality and so when the
press kept asking me about all the devil
stuff it just kept adding to the
pressure I was under and it was just an
awful thing to go through as a teenager
can you feel this I don't feel anything
[Music]